évidemment moins des monnaies puisque
vous savez qu'on parle de britney spears
qui va toucher un pactole pour ses
mémoires donc depuis la levée de la
tutelle voilà elle fait ce qu'elle veut
et donc elle a signé un accord de 15
millions de dollars 13 millions d'euros
avec la maison une maison d'édition pour
écrire ses mémoires elle revient sur ma
toute sa vie dont 15 millions d'euros
encore une fois c'est ce qu'a touché
barack obama c'est quand même juste
hallucinant et on va y apprendre plein
plein plein de choses de danse par
exemple qu'est-ce qu'on veille à prendre
florian chacon à 4 infos exclusives qui
sont dans ce bouquin alors moi je me
suis forcément intéressé 1 1 fait en
particulier c'est pourquoi s'en souvient
tous elle s'est rasé le crâne un jour
devant les caméras les noix et
objectivement rien de ça alors elle
était en procès à l'époque avec elle
allait être en procès avec son ancien
manager sam lufti qui l'a accusée au
long du procès d'avoir fait ça pour ne
pas qu'on puisse s'apercevoir qu'elle
était souvent fait sous amphétamines
garder la garde de ses enfants ce qui
est en procès avec son ex et c est ce
que tout le monde ne sait pas c'est
qu'on peut trouver des traces
d'amphétamines de drogue et de plein
d'autres choses dans les cheveux il est
à l'abri vous tranquille c'est pour ça
j'ai fait un choix radical ya longtemps
je suis peinard et elle en fait elle l'a
fait c'est ce qui va être racontée dans
le plat je donne pas tout dit qu'on peut
entendre et de l'aider des traces de
drogue jusqu'à un an dans les cheveux et
c'est pour ça notamment que les
cyclistes les cyclistes sera entièrement
exactement et plus grands comptes qui
sont morts comme pop tannique et morne
une overdose de 2,2 de stimulants bas il
était complètement rasée il sera sous
les jambes c'est pour autre chose pour
les pensées en mai à meyrannes c'est
parce qu'on peut remonter par sensible à
ce qu'on peut savoir si on allait de la
drogue dans le sang au moment m au
moment d choper ac le avec les cheveux
on remonte sur une période donnée comme
ça que même napoléon normand tendance en
le dp rampant dans ses cheveux là dessus
qu'il avait au moins étaient enterrés à
il avait empoisonné au cyanure parce
qu'on est membre du cyanure dans ses
cheveux etc ces essais c'est la mémoire
c'est comme la glace de l'antarctique
est bas les cheveux c'est la mémoire de
l'homme paraît donc elle allait perdre à
elle à garder ses enfants voilà elle
n'avait pas la garde de ses enfants et
la tête et ça n'a jamais été confirmée
de façon il faut lire le livre je pense
il yad'autres mal dans leur peau ce
qu'elle va faire la révélation dans
l'est absolument déjà été votre mari
dont kevin ferderline cessa deborah
qu'est ce qu'est le débat public marie
ève abe va dire je pense à parler de la
pension alimentaire s'élève à peu près
20 mille dollars par mois qu'elle
continue de paix aujourd'hui une minute
et avait été décidé de mon temps sous
tutelle par exactement et oui
apparemment voudrait aussi augmenter
cette pension alimentaire et recevoir
encore plus à oui mais cela est toujours
amis de base sans rien [ __ ] savate et
anan bah oui moi je trouve ça va il fait
plus rien déjà elle parle de ses amitiés
notamment ses sales gosses qu'on a
appris aussi dans le bouquin la part de
ses amitiés parce qu'on se dit que
justin timberlake c'était son ex et
qu'elle peut reconnaître quand il se
souvient de l'époque où elle traînait
beaucoup avec paris hilton lindsay lohan
ou voilà après c'est vrai que pendant
les treize ans que tutelle les amitiés
se sont un peu éloignés elle s'est
retrouvée quand même très isolés je
pense qu'aujourd'hui hormis madonna avec
qui elle a gardé un lien proches elle le
dit souvent dans ses publications des
réseaux sociaux je crois qu'aujourd'hui
elle est quand même très isolée elle a
pas beaucoup d'amis dans les stars ni
des amis tout court d'ailleurs filature
et sur madonna brad est ce que nous
aurons encore des infos exact qui tout à
l'heure parce que vous allez voir que
c'est quelque chose madonna visiblement
je crois que de l'avis de tout le monde
ce que j'en suis la sixième personne que
je connais que elle a 25 ans non c'est
certain c'est une grande artiste mais
elle c'est un bulbe menace se comporte
très mal c'est vrai ou pas ça jacki à ça
je ne sais pas au côté jacky vous n'avez
pas me faire de langue de bois toutes
les missions non que ce soit une
[ __ ] ne se comporte pas bien
elle a des exigences gimondi va dire oui
pardon je rappelle que notre parti
mais à ce point là c'était une diva
c'était une vivante est une diva moi je
me rappelle d'une madonna tellement
différente de celle qu'on nous présente
aujourd'hui c'est l intouchable même
mais n'en dit pas plus ce serait bien
qu'on aura on aura tout sur les divas
dans un instant et alors il ya aussi
autre chose qui était assez hallucinant
je crois mathilde s'est alors ça c'est
hallucinant j'ai appris que l avait eu
pendant sa tutelle elle avait un
stérilet la voie stérile et c'est ça et
la vf se son père il envie de me sentir
il est pendante est resté dans le
contrat de tutelle socis ne l avais un
stérilet donc interdit d'avoir d'enfant
et pas droit de se marier surtout parce
qu'il faut savoir quel sort avec son
coach sportif depuis 2016 et qu'elle
palois de se marier avec lui parce que
dans le contrat tutelles c'était le
mariage était impossible et avoir des
enfants c'était impossible sauf que là
depuis qu'elle est sous tutelle elle a
annoncé sur instagram qu'elle
souhaiterait agrandir sa famille et
accueillir un nouveau fin pour ça que la
face au tfc bah oui parce que sinon ces
comptes et pourtant elle n'est pas
enceinte mais stérile et dans le bouquin
ça fait un joli bouquet savate shirani à
périgueux revendre sur le bon coin ont
pas